the other thing too we should we should
look at why didn't the Red Wave come and
we should be very honest with ourselves
there's a couple different reasons why
and I'll tell you look as leader
I'm fortunate in both terms we've won
but could could we have one more yeah we
could have
I had three candidates in Pennsylvania
that overperformed the Republican
gubernatorial candidate by 2014 and 11
and did not win
this idea that
we're just going to pick whoever and
think we're going to win in November no
the top of the ticket is going to hurt
you below the ticket and this idea that
we're it almost happens that we're
better at attacking other Republicans
than standing up for the policies we
believe in
you guys give a very nice welcome to the
speaker
thank you
we did a press conference in here and it
wasn't like you'd see before like the
membership and we invited parents and
kids and we invited parents that had the
challenges right one was you'll remember
him the father from Loudoun County that
his daughter oh yeah he comes and tells
his story but
then you have a young mother from Rhode
Island her her child went to
um kindergarten all she wanted to know
what's on the curriculum they said well
you got to ask us you got to put it
written for him she goes well okay well
then I had 100 questions then they had a
meeting to sue her to ask for she was
asking questions it was unbelievable and
you think at times these stories that
they just happen in one little place you
know you hear about that male swimmer
against the women well no when you start
having the discussion it's happening
everywhere and so we like to bring more
people in and the other thing we're
doing taking our hearings out of
Washington we've had them along the
border we've had them in different parts
of the country make the Committees go
out to listen to the public
you can make some noise for that
I also like the way we started that I
didn't even have to ask a question you
could just talk
I'll just sit here with my legs crossed
for an hour and we'll make it work we've
been interviewed before yeah he used
he's like most people in California he
used to live there now he moved to
Florida but uh we I'd go down to his
house and we'd do a show well let's
start actually since since you talked
about the parental rights uh vote which
did pass but not one Democrat voted for
it five Republicans voted against it
um transparency that's all it was about
and I find when I when I talk to these
guys I listen to my audience that's what
most people want right now out of
government whether it's the schools or
whether it's here in DC just show us
what's going on be honest with us don't
treat us like children are you shocked
that not one Democrat could vote for it
and because I can't go you know more
than a minute without talking about AOC
uh unfortunately that in her speech
where she was railing against it she
called it fascism she called it fascism
I take it nothing's probably surprises
you at this now you know what's
interesting and this is what people have
to understand and I've come to
understand now with these different
they're very extreme in their beliefs
I mean think about we in Congress when
you put a bill across the desk HR is the
house resolution number right and it
gets stamped by the order in which you
go but the majority reserves one through
ten
and the Democrats get 11 through 20.
okay so you can pick what's most
important now our number one bill is
going to be hr1 which we'll vote on this
week and that'll be for energy
Independence okay the Democrats were in
the majority their number one bill was
election law reform that they wanted to
rig the system that would make taxpayers
pay for it and have a czar and all that
we made the parents Bill of Rights hr5
for a couple different reasons one
that's when kindergarten starts your
five years old but it really had five
pillars
parents should know what's being taught
in the school give us the curriculum
don't make us go have to find it send it
to us and what books are there to read
they say we're Banning books we never
said anything about just tell us what
you want us to read right shouldn't we
know the next thing we saw you should we
should know how do you spend the money
it's taxpayer money what's it being
spent on in schools is it going just the
administration is going where is it
going
we want to protect our children's
privacy are they selling the data right
we want to know is there a violent
activity because what will happen is a
child may be heard on campus but you're
only telling those two children that
father what happened to him he went and
told but the person who that molested
his daughter had already done it before
and the last part is a parent has a
right to be heard you should be able to
go to a school board meeting
and not say you're a terrorist
I'm a big conservative Federalist and
all that that's not getting a school
board that's just respect in the process
and that's just transparency I'm very
big on transparency
um the Democrats try to attack me all
the time when I provide information when
they try to only show certain parts well
let the public make that decision that's
the difference I think when we had this
discussion before I was born into a
democratic family but never a Democrat
so I really think my philosophy and
beliefs are stronger than others because
I chose to reject what I heard for
something different and what I believe
in a philosophy I trust you I'm going to
give you the information but I also
trust you to fail or succeed I'm not
going to predetermine that
so I don't want to do just policy here
because I'm guessing how many of you is
this the first time either in or in the
capital itself I assume many of you
right so fabulous yeah so how weird is
it on just a day-to-day basis that
you're in this building right now where
pretty much everyone's here right now
for the most part right and you're in
this building with these people that the
ideas are just so diametrically opposed
with each other and you know they say
some pretty nasty things about you and
you've got to say some things about them
and sometimes they're on your side of
the aisle doing that yeah no no look if
you follow the speaker's race most
people win on the first round okay
we had a rough week we had a rough week
but you know what I'm Irish
I have the best fights in my
neighborhood right and most fights go 15
rounds so that's okay but I'll tell you
I'll tell you a story so so if you watch
the speakers race there was there's one
staffer who sat next to me at John
leganski and everybody wants to know
he's a really smart kid he went to
Stanford he interned for he's the
youngest guy ever on the floor and his
brothers about to become an ordained
priest and his brother sent him a Book
of Prayers you know before it all and he
went and we would keep a tally sheet of
everybody's name that you keep voting
and before the speaker votes right he
just put a handful down there and when
the speaker race was over
I said you know what
we always knew it was going to go to 15.
I said well how did we always know he
goes you know I didn't get a chance to
finish all the prayers in the book and
this week and I did you know how many
prayers were in that book 15 prayers he
goes you know how many ballots I'd just
take I just grabbed a handful put down
there 15.
so sometimes God has a plan for you you
just don't know it yet right I could
have been speaker before we're in the
majority it was going to be handed to me
but I made a mistake on on a interview
and lo and behold pull back we went back
into the minority and an interesting
thing happened so four years ago I
became leader of the Republican party
and Pelosi became speaker we have a
five-seat majority in those four years
we picked up six more seats six
Democrats lost their congressional seats
in California no one writes about this
she lost her majority in her home state
that people think is really blue right
but we were able to win
um if anyone ever wants to run for
office this is what I would tell you and
how long should the members stay in
office if you don't get goosebumps
looking at that Capital walking into
this building it's time for you to leave
right I feel so privileged to even have
this opportunity right I get goosebumps
now just talking to you about it think
about we're sitting in the Rayburn room
right the chambers is right there
those chambers
were opened in 1857. George Washington
was never sworn in here right George
Washington sworn in on Wall Street and
in Philadelphia okay
every president since has either been
sworn in on the east side over on the
West Side the first president be sworn
on the west side was Reagan he'd tell
you he wanted to look towards California
right but my favorite place in this
whole building if you go and take a tour
is that room right there it's Statuary
Hall so when the building was first
built the Country Wasn't 50 states it
wasn't as large people had desks this
Dome is the second Dome they had to
enlarge the Dome when they enlarged the
building like the Supreme Court was over
on the Senate side so that was the
chambers and it's really a nice floor it
wasn't thin it was spatoons people
spinning people had fights because this
was both this was before the Civil War
right
but they put they put a tile with anyone
who ever been a member of Congress that
became president so you could see where
they sat so if you go all the way in the
back there's a tile there it's but like
um father Sierra
there's a tile in front of it it's where
Abraham Lincoln said he was a one-term
congressman that's all he served and he
so he sat in the back and he was kind of
um
it was kind of a quiet man and if you go
in the back back there they had like a
mail room and we call it the Lincoln
room he'd go back there and tell his
stories but I like to stand right where
that tile is stand there and look front
like at the front of it Envision it
being loud you're right that had
microphones on it and then look back
and look at the lady above the clock she
she still she's supposed to be
inscribing what happens there and just
look at the clock and and pause and look
at the time right look at the time say
oh it's 2 30. and you want to know why
that's my favorite spot that's the same
clock the same view Abraham Lincoln had
and I'll promise you he's looked at it
many times and you're standing right
where he is right runs for Senate loses
runs for president and this is one of
the things that drives me as a
republican
um
he's the first Republican president
here's a nation not even know if it's
going to sustain itself he builds the
Intercontinental Railroad that's like
inventing the internet right during the
time that he's looking that the future
is going to be brighter
but this is what I think all Americans
should pause did you see that poll in
the Wall Street Journal where we're not
patriotic anymore we don't want to have
children we're not religious that
concerns me
and what I would say is
look at Lincoln's words right
and what I believe if Lincoln if he was
interviewing Lincoln today and Lincoln
was here Lincoln would first take off
his top hat he'd be a tall man he has a
high voice
but he would tell you about the
Gettysburg Address you know four score
and seven years ago our forefathers
brought forth on this continent a new
nation right conceived in liberty and
dedicated the proposition that we're all
equal he goes on to say but if we fail
government of the People by the people
for the people Cheryl shall not perish
from Earth but think about when he wrote
this and why he said it okay we're not
the world power
we're not even a country or divided but
he knew America was more than a country
an idea that we would still sustain
ourselves the concept
of by the people for the people is more
powerful than anything else but name me
one other Nation that's conceived in
liberty and dedicated the proposition
that the world equal we're not a perfect
Nation we strive to be a more perfect
Nation but we should be more patriotic
I mean this idea and this is goes long
answer to your short question I will put
bills on the phone I don't even remember
the question
I just now did I think I asked you what
it's like to work in a place when people
don't like you okay so
we had a resolution on the floor
denouncing socialism okay this is not a
college campus this is not Berkeley this
is people elected to the U.S House of
Representatives with all the history of
America and a hundred Democrats couldn't
vote no
can you believe that so it goes back to
your question could I believe that not
one Democrat would stand up that's an
extreme position and and I say this with
all due respect the Democrats where I
grew up they were not that way yeah you
would find places here and look we have
passed I'll get this wrong in the last
weekend somewhere about 43 or 48 bills
okay
over like 37 have all been bipartisan
there's been more than 4 000 Democrat
votes on these right and so you can find
common ground with both sides but how
can it not be common ground that parents
can know what's being taught in their
kids school
no way do they get to say what's what
the curriculum or what the what the
books are being read just tell us what
you're doing and that's wrong so how do
we get over that because I think that
that seems to be probably the fur
there's a lot of problems but that seems
to be the first one that when you look
back and you go okay well these guys
aren't you know they are afraid to
denounce socialism they many of them do
view the founding of the country as a
net negative to the world things of that
nature how do we get past that before we
get into the battles of okay you want
this tax break and you want that
spending Bill well it's tough too
because it's just like on DC crime now
all of you stay safe here but you know
DC is not a state they want to make it a
state
and the city council went and
decriminalized carjacking even forms of
murder
so we could do something about it we put
it on the floor
to not allow that to happen
one member on the Democratic side got
mugged on her way to work and she lives
in a really nice area it's but it's not
unusual right you talk to staff it
happens all the time Rand Paul is one of
his staff members was stabbed two days
ago I think he's I think he's incredible
the other weekend before in broad
daylight in the middle of the weekend at
a gunpoint robbed and the um the phone
and everything else taken carjackings we
did this in February at that time there
were we had only about 30 some days into
the new year and there were 65
carjackings when we passed this the
president said he would veto it only 31
Democrats voted with us that that's not
a partisan issue to be safe and so what
is it you hear from them what do you
hear privately when they vote against
this they think they have to lock
together that somehow oh that I'm
agreeing with the Republican no you want
your streets safe
you know and they said but
DC should be a state and we should have
our hands off now the Delegate for D.C
Norton she did a rally before it was
going to come back right and she had it
at Union Station in the middle of the
day at three o'clock and if you watch
the video of the rally somebody gets
carjacked during the round you can't
make this up you can't make it up
but this is the other thing and this is
what scares me so it was it wasn't just
about DC it's about what's happening
across this nation in crime from Chicago
and others and I believe there are some
waking up but the majority are not
because they think they can't stand up
to them D.C also says anybody can vote
okay we're in a we're in pretty much an
international city are we not because
you have all these embassies so you can
belong to the Chinese Communist party
I'd be a Chinese and work at that
Embassy in DC now said you can vote in
in your elections here what do you think
they would want to vote for and
embarrass our nation's capital
that's what concerns me that that's
beyond common sense that's an extreme
position that goes beyond the foundation
of the nation so what do you think
Republicans can do better than one of
the lines that these guys hear me say
probably five times a week is you don't
have to be a republican but you cannot
be a Democrat and the reason I frame it
that way is it's obvious they've for the
most part gone off the deep end but
there's a there clearly is some sort of
branding issue or something that I think
might be changing I do believe that that
you know for example the Republicans
obviously didn't get that red wave in
the midterm so people clearly are
stepping away from the Democrats but
they're kind of I don't know these
Republicans the other thing too we
should we should look at why didn't the
Red Wave come and we should be very
honest with ourselves there's a couple
different reasons why and I'll tell you
look as leader
I'm fortunate in both terms we've won
but
could could we have one more yeah we
could have
I had three candidates in Pennsylvania
that overperformed the Republican
gubernatorial candidate by 2014 and 11
and did not win
this idea that
we're just going to pick whoever and
think we're going to win in November no
the top of the ticket is going to hurt
you below the ticket and this idea that
we're it almost happens that we're
better at attacking other Republicans
than standing up for the policies we
believe in well that gets us nowhere
and the other thing too is if you want
to be in the majority and this is what
Reagan said if you agree with us 80 of
the time you're there
somebody who wins in Texas is going to
be different than someone who wins in
California and if you want to sit back
and where did we win the majority well
five new seats in New York we won in
California we want in Oregon we won in
Arizona places that other Republicans
lost and to be frank
in the last two cycles we've lost the
presidency both Cycles lost in the
Senate we've lost Governors the only
place we've won is in the house and the
one thing I will say the determining
Factor the quality of a candidate we
have an extraordinary candidates who've
won and sometimes it's very important to
get the right person through the primary
and you shouldn't just say okay well
this person is the most conservative
well who's the most conservative who can
win in November that's another thing we
have to think because you've got to have
the gavel to govern the uniqueness like
we have a five-seat majority
they don't hand the gavels out in small
medium and large we get the same size
gavel so and and this is a place as
Republicans should wake up so I look
look back at the vote saying where could
we have done better
top of the ticket hurt
um
Supreme Court decision made a difference
too in different places where the
Democrats played it it did so you think
it hurt more than anticipated maybe yeah
much more than the polling showed it
determined turnout and motivation
um in 2012 we had 234 members and we
didn't even win the popular vote in the
house in 2016 we peaked we had 242
members and we won the popular vote by
one point today we have 222 members you
know what our popular vote was we want
to buy three points two points better
than the time before seven points better
than we did two years prior so what it
means is it's more competitive we've had
redistricting so it's not that you're
going to have these big majorities that
you think things are just going to
happen and
people look through different points
right I mean think for a moment how many
are from Pennsylvania
the one thing I learned is Democrats
will vote for whoever as long as they're
a Democrat
you know
but I will tell you where is John
Federman where is he
I don't know but I'm just you know all
due respect I mean
it's just very difficult but Republicans
and and this is where I say we've got to
be honest with ourselves and we got to
do it before you get the election
if we have a poor candidate
rightfully so we won't we won't all walk
and lock step and vote for that person
right for yourself so what we really
should do in the primary not beat up on
each other but pick the very best person
who's going to be able to win and carry
it and sometimes we say if you're not no
one's going to be a hundred percent with
each other but do we have a core
foundation with one another I'll tell
you guys something funny about John
fetterman I actually saw Dr Oz a couple
weeks ago at Jordan Peterson's house at
a party and he looked like he got
punched in the face the guy cannot
believe that he lost to fetterman it is
still
anywho
um what do you what do you make of as
you know I I lived in Cali I made a very
public exit to the free state of Florida
things seem to not give it up I'm not
giving up
you know I didn't want to leave that
house but that was the only thing that
was keeping me there was a was a home I
didn't want to leave that house
um
but what do you make of the general idea
now that the states do seem to be going
their separate way and that is what
Federalism is all about and Cal I mean I
feel like a new country each state is a
pilot program yeah and if there's one
thing you look in the nation right every
10 years we do a census this is the
first time in the history of California
that we've lost a congressional seat the
time before we stayed equal and what
states lost New York California Illinois
what state States game Texas and Florida
it's a pilot program that's telling the
country right and how many you have
friends that have moved why because of
the policies and it should it should
wake the other states up
I mean do you have any hope for Cali I
mean obviously you're still a
representative in Cali I mean look I
hope that that thing can yeah because
look I've won five seats in the last
four years in California Republican in
Congress
um they make the system harder the other
thing you have to remember too
California has when it comes to election
law they mail everybody a ballot whether
you ask for one or not they don't clean
up their roles they make it legal that
you can
um Harvest somebody's ballot and we
still win so it doesn't matter what
state you live in find what the rules
are and go out and fight for what you
believe in the hard part is most people
who are leaving California have a more
conservative View and you know these
other states say oh we don't want the
government I want them back you know
there are a lot of the other voters but
we're learning and also the other thing
too is if you look at the Republican
party now in the house
more women more minorities the most
black Republicans since reconstruction
so don't think we can't compete anywhere
in the country we can't but I believe
it's the policy and so I don't give up
because the pendulum always swings how
much do you view the mainstream media as
an impediment to what you're trying to
do at this point they they obviously are
losing control to a certain degree but
you know every day on the show I'm
putting out the lies of the view and the
lies of Meet the Press and the lies of
CNN and MSNBC and the whole thing uh
they're they're never with you guys they
don't mind lying over and over and over
again do you view it as a problem still
or in some ways is it a win because we
can expose it now well I think
the American public on both sides of the
aisle do not trust what they're being
told most of the time because because
they found that it hasn't been there's
lots of times that it hasn't been right
I live in each and every day
I can walk up and do a press conference
I tell you on right after passing the
parents Bill of Rights and they'll ask
me something about something else right
but to tell you the secret is I kind of
enjoy the battle now I don't know if you
watch any of my press conferences I
decided when I became speaker
I'm going to do something different I I
do I do a lot of things different Hakeem
Jeffrey's office is right where that
used to be my office but I'm I treat
Hakeem the way I wanted to be treated
and I think that's we should
we should be the first ones that respect
people who have difference of opinion
others because we get upset if people
don't give us the respect of our
opinions well how can you do that if you
don't respect so I I try to provide
there but I don't go down and do a press
conference in The Press Room I do it
Statuary Hall I do it out here and they
they all come around me and they ask me
some of them they'll ask me this one
question when I was dealing from the
beginning about
um on Intel I removed shift and swallow
I did it for a purpose not for a
political purpose and this one reporter
asked me the question and then as soon
as I start to answer she says I'm not
answering the question so my point is
well you have a right to ask me the
question but you do not have a right to
say whether I answered or not my answer
is your answer
but I mean think about it I was really
concerned about Intel committees
different than all the other committees
this is where you get the security
clearance okay
the members who sit on there only get
appointed by their leaders
um
they they find things out that other
members don't right and we make
decisions in there to protect all of us
with information we know and because of
source and others you really can't let
other people know well shift used that
position to lie about what he knew which
you can't be there
swallow got on as a sophomore and the
minute he gets on the FBI comes tells us
he's got a relationship with a Chinese
spy no disrespect I just don't think
that qualifies you right
um no disrespect no disrespect there's
200 other members she could appoint it
right yeah I never knew about this till
I came later that I read in the paper
the FBI come and give me the briefing
there's no way it should have been on
their phone there and so I just said no
anybody that has a relationship with any
spy you can't be on the committee it's
just I mean it's not a high bar but
wait I have to I have to pause you for a
sec because because when I had you at
the house in Cali you told me about that
for the first time was the first time I
heard about it and we then clipped that
a million times and it got millions of
views and people were sharing it before
you were a speaker and now but he's
still here he's still in this building
if you have a relationship with the
Chinese spy no disrespect isn't that I
just became very Italian do you see that
is it isn't that just like you got to go
now like you can't stay here you don't
have to go home but I I believe in in
the in the rule of law the voters decide
who their member of Congress is I could
dislike that person I could think that
person did something wrong but there's
nothing that disqualifies him
from being a member that's why I he's a
member and I give them uh committees but
I'm not giving you a security clearance
he cannot if he was to leave this job
and he went to the private sector he
could not get a security clearance
because he had a relationship with a
Chinese spy so why would we give him a
government security clearance and they
attacked me for it and so what I did I
went down when the Intel committee first
constituted and I had Hakeem come with
me and I told all the members look I
want you to work together I don't want
partisanship in this office because this
is a committee that should think just as
Americans right and this is the other
thing I'm doing I'm really afraid
which country captures Ai and Quantum
first okay and we should be really
concerned as Americans of what's
happening with Russia China North Korea
and Iran if you study history this is
very similar to the 1930s they're
creating an axis of power of supporting
one another against the West democracy
and freedom
the only two times president XI has left
his country since the pandemic was to
meet with this group
it's very concerning to me and so MIT
teaches a course in Quantum and AI that
they actually provide to the generals in
our military I'm having everybody on the
Intel take it together so they think
like a SWAT right a strength weakness
opportunity threats you think is an
American not as a republican a Democrat
right because whatever happens if we
fail it's not one party failing it's a
nation that's failing and I'm going to
have them come in and teach it to the
entire Congress you know the only time
we really get together outside of
committees and cameras is when we have
classified briefings and it's usually
about a thread a balloon or something
else right
and so
I recently had one where all the
Republicans and Democrats went together
in the auditorium and you know what it
was about our debt
and I didn't make it partisan I had the
Congressional budget office come in and
tell because this is this is what you
should be worried about too look we have
a lot of problems we have a border
that's not secure we have fentanyl
coming across we have inflation all that
but the three greatest biggest
challenges I think to our nation going
forward is our debt our education system
in China okay and we're not going to
tackle those unless you're tackle
together and what I wanted to do is not
in a partisan way but really look at
this debt the CBO tells us in the next
10 years
we'll have to pay 10.5 trillion just in
interest okay but let me put in
perspective 10.5 trillion in the next 10
years do you know how much we paid an
interest since 1940 till today
in those 83 years 9 trillion
this is the interest on your credit card
okay people this is what makes you upset
and for the first time in the next 10
years three of the trust funds will go
broke Highway Medicare and Social
Security and the president all yells oh
Republicans want to cut it no by him
doing nothing it automatically gets cut
he's cutting it by ignoring this problem
and if you look at 50-year averages on
50-year average we normally spend about
21 percent of GDP okay right now he's
spending 23.7 on his way to 25 percent
on average amount of Revenue we bring in
on 50 years is usually about
17.1 percent do you know how much
revenue per GDP we're bringing right now
20 you know how many times we've done
that in the history of America only
twice so it's not
it's not a revenue problem we have more
money at any given time
coming in but we're spending they added
5.9 trillion and they wonder why
inflation was black and what happened
when inflation came interest rates went
up and now it causes a banking problem
and then he wants to ignore the debt
ceiling like someone should just pass
that without changing it and to me the
debt ceiling is you give your child a
credit card they charge it up you're
responsible for paying it but did you
just raise the limit or you look at what
they're spending it on
so that's the approach I'm taking and
it's pretty hard that the president
tries to ignore it do you admire
sometimes the fact that they can get
away with this kind of stuff I mean the
inflation reduction act which
doesn't have anything to do with
inflation right I mean it literally
caused inflation but but they get away
with it the media runs cover for them
and then you have to come out here and
explain you know things about growth and
GDP and people are like but the
inflation reduction act you know you got
to be strong-willed in this and you got
to have a willingness not to give up
because you could work as hard as you
can they could say something that's not
true but you've got to wake up the next
day and come back you know this country
is too great for small ideas right and
I just believe even in the last election
maybe it didn't turn out exactly as you
wanted but think about had we not won
the majority of the house what would be
happening and sometimes
we've got to thank for what we got right
then and work harder that's exactly what
we have to do I'm thankful if you get
out and tell the story
we're trying I mean we're trying and
what's interesting I think that you'd
find from this audience if I polled
these guys you know my audience is kind
of all over the place there's probably a
couple
two maybe maybe at most Democrats there
might be two in here
Maybe not maybe not three you see that
everybody kind of froze not me there
might be Democrats who listen they're
definitely former Democrats how about
former Democrats right again right
exactly
yeah
let me ask you about about the hearings
we're always watching hearings I'm
always playing clips of hearings and
we're dragging out Twitter Executives
and all of these people and fouchy you
know can lie about uh vaccines or what
we funded and all of this stuff we play
these clips and people are like oh it's
great Rand Paul got them and this
happened that happened Ted Cruz got him
but then no one gets fired nothing seems
to actually change and I think that that
is now something that you guys that's my
personal advice would be that that's
something that you guys should be
focusing on like what happens after the
hearing it's not enough for us to just
be like oh fouchy lied Twitter executive
slide Etc okay so let's think about this
let's let's also look at what has
happened since we won the majority we
won the majority weren't sworn in yet
but we were able to get in the ndaa
that those in the service no longer
mandate that they had to have the
vaccine so they weren't going to be
kicked out that's a victory right so
they stopped firing people that there
is it a coincident that fauci then
announced that he wasn't going to stay
around
do you know something else that we
created we created a select committee on
covid is it a coincidence that once we
start the hearings then they acknowledge
well there is information that it could
have come from the Wuhan lab of the
Wuhan covet right even
who was the guy that used to have the
nighttime show the comedian oh Jon
Stewart when he brought it he brought it
up yeah yeah yeah they they named a lab
afterwards
[Music]
um it's interesting now now they're
providing certain information as we're
going after they make it very difficult
now that we have subpoena power
but I think you'll find at the end of
the day when we get the information now
we're not going to predetermine
if we don't have all the facts we're
going to take people through and see all
the facts and I think what's another
thing that's happening in this country
that's a problem there's no consequences
for people's action that's what's
happened with crime that's what's
happened in our schools right and when
they see it happening in government then
why should they not and I think that's
part of the point look so how does that
actually change I mean do you need a
Republican president to then do
something about it so let's say the laws
you expose these guys okay we fauci lied
under oath let's just let's just say is
a job anymore right so okay but but one
of these or if we found out who exactly
at the government was guiding we also
changed
some of the rules in the house when we
took over so I mean it's hard for us
like you get mad at somebody okay defund
the whole department well that doesn't
work you don't have to do something now
we have a specific place we can go so we
can go there but what's interesting to
me you brought up Twitter and I think
elon's doing a fabulous job there to be
honest with you and what Elon is doing
not picking signs he's just letting the
information out and the Democrats are
getting mad right but we watched what
happened that it's even worse than we
imagined that government was in
with business now going after people on
what their beliefs were but then he had
some Democrat reporters right what
happened to Matt the other day the IRS
comes to his house
so sometimes our hearing shows light
stops actions
we're not prosecutors so we can't we
can't prosecute somebody or we can
defund certain jobs but we don't have
the ability to prosecute someone we have
the ability to show the light and give
all the information and also controls
purse strings so we'll take every Power
we have to try to correct actions
what else is on your mind that may not
be on our mind I mean and by our mind I
mean the things that I'm talking about
on the show the things that these guys
are talking about like what else is
coming down the pike that that you're
either worried about or excited for look
I I
an American
do you want to live somewhere else it
may not be perfect here but we have an
opportunity to make it better right so
every day I'm an optimist I wake up
every day if this is the one current
thing I'm worried about how the
president's handling the debt ceiling
he's ignoring it he's walking Us in to
some type of debt problem because he's
just ignoring the problem I'm worried
about the Next Generation we're at 120
percent of GDP in debt we've only been
here during World War II that means our
debt's larger than our economy with
another 20 percent
so what are you doing to the resonation
um so when you say that to your
colleagues on the other side what do
they say I mean do they fundamentally
just believe you can just print money I
mean because they yeah they
fundamentally that's the belief that's
actually the belief that's what caused
look Milton Friedman was my favorite
Economist he said there's only one
entity that can create inflation
government
when they spend too much he also says
there's only one way out of inflation is
that the interest rates have to be
higher than the inflation rate well we
can't afford that
you're going to be interest rates over
six seven percent it's going to be good
then I'm worried about the future I I
look at these other four countries
creating access of power I've watched
what
I've watched what a lack of leadership
has happened okay think about when the
president got in
Afghanistan
creating 13 new gold star families so
you know what we had a hearing on this
for the whole time they never went and
had a hearing because they're afraid of
what they're going to find out why would
you do that to our military you want to
never repeat that he didn't listen to
the military leaders he made his own
decision we actually had a sniper that
had the bomber
in his in his uh in his sights okay but
where did that bomber come from take it
a step back further he was in the prison
in Bagram so had he not moved out of
Bagram where we caught the worst people
for the last decade that person would
have never got out and got and put a
bomb on To Kill The Americans
and then they wouldn't look at the
system so but what happened after that
it set us back two decades the
chancellor of Germany now goes to China
China has now just brokered a deal in
the Middle East between Saudi Arabia and
Iran that used to be the leadership of
America Camp David right so what he's
done is he's lowered the standards of
America to our allies and to our
adversaries pushing them further there
it also brought upon Ukraine right
because then he goes meets with Putin
Putin saw what happened in Afghanistan
and what does he do when he meets with
Putin he lifts the sanctions off North
stream too he gives him a welcome map
back in 2015 I met with then Vice
President Biden trying to encourage him
to sell the javelins to Ukraine so they
can stop if any Russian tanks come in he
says no Merkel won't like that I said
well let's train him on and keep it in
Poland so it's there close no
remember when he spent too much and he
told us inflation was transitory
it's the worst punishment you can ever
do to your own citizens it takes money
directly out of you and he told us it
was transitory then the interest rates
went up then Banks got in trouble we're
weaker around the world then he comes
out and he picks one form of energy
makes our energy cost higher cuts jobs
out of America it harms emissions let me
tell you this
American natural gas is 41 cleaner than
Russian Natural Gas
if we sell American Natural Gas not just
to our allies to our adversaries Global
emissions will go down further than any
Democrat bill out there and you know
what else will happen geopolitically the
world will be safer there'll be more
American jobs you'll have a better
environment you'll have a stronger
America you'll have a safer world and he
tells us I'm going to veto that on
demand what
makes no sense
don't you care about the country don't
you care about the world
and all he does is Empower his Ira Bill
inflation reduction
that's a stimulus bill for China
mandating one form of energy where are
you going to buy the windmills where are
you going to buy the solar panels China
and if you watch what he's done is he
shut down our minerals China controls 90
percent of all critical minerals they
control 95 percent of the processing so
when we open up a new mine in America we
got to send them over there to be
processed one thing we did do when we
took the majority I've been wanting to
do this for four years I created the
select committee on China
okay
the things that we have failed at we
have not spoken with one voice about
China has systematically we used to
Copper key and all these Renewables and
everything else back in the 90s we
produced three times as much they now
produce eight times why because they've
gone around the world collecting it why
we shut ours down why are we empowering
them we shouldn't be dependent upon them
on anything
we should bring it back to America and
back to to just North and South America
as well and what he's done is make us
weaker on that stage and it's only been
two years so what keeps me up is that
leadership
who do you think is driving that I mean
so you believe that that this is really
Joe Biden himself
[Music]
quite a few times
it's him and remember when he was
running for president
he was about to be beaten they all
collapsed right and then he had to go
and publicly sign an agreement with
Bernie Sanders
when he gave the State of the Union one
of my toughest jobs was just to sit
behind there right and I was respectful
I did not tear up the speech I could
disagree
[Applause]
there's a difference in speakers I
respect the office I have I respect his
office I respect him in his office
um I Heard Democrats yelling to Bernie
Sanders you wrote that speech you wrote
that speech in Bernie's smiling remember
what he pledged to get their votes
that's where he went so far that's the
extreme position and remember Bernie
Sanders is not a Democrat he's a
socialist and he's never walked away
from that
did you happen to see the clip of Bernie
on Real Time with Bill Maher a couple
weeks ago where he asked him the
difference between equity and equality
which is the entire socialist program
and Bernie literally said he didn't know
and then Bill had to walk him through it
I mean it's incredible has been pretty
interesting we're trying to get him
there
you ever get the call you ever get the
call no I've been on that show before
I was on that show before I was ever
elected
I was a young Republican
yeah now don't go back and try to find
the kill yeah
but but not getting the call these days
let's see
there was a Diane Von Furstenberg the
design she was on it yeah yeah one of
the guys that was on a uh he had a hit
show at the time
and then I think a comedian well what do
you what do you think you got to do to
get those last liberals these guys know
I focus on that group because I always
say there's not that many people that
can shift right now right we have you
have your hardcore Republicans you have
your hardcore Democrats but I think the
disaffected liberal is the group that
you can still shift it is the Bill Maher
types which is why I focus on him so
much you know we'd sit back and say like
what what am I doing to shift them I
actually think the Democrats are doing
more to shift them
I think we I think if we ask Bill more
about me four years ago he said Kevin
doesn't have anything nice to say right
he say I don't believe anything he says
I think he's so disgusted by these
Democrat policies and what's really
happened is when the Democrats took
control of everything
what brought US inflation what brought
defunding of the police what brought us
crime you know and then they try to they
try to just
give talking points that they're like
they're strong on crime we'll know
I mean did you put anyone in jail that
was burning our federal buildings no
I mean and what what's really concerning
to America now too is
we respect the rule of law we respect
Equal justice but when Justice is only
weighed on one side that's what we don't
like that is what gets us infuriated and
I really think what the Democrats have
done has moved Bill Barr more that he
said this is no longer Where I Stood and
I really wonder in time if you look back
in history for a million times
would John Kennedy be a Democrat today
no his policies are not where the
Democratic party is at anti-war low tax
yeah what would the world what would
America have looked like had Abraham
Lincoln not been assassinated right
malice towards none we wouldn't wait
until the 1950s the Civil Rights and
this is something for people who are
Republican and conservative
don't let the Democrats take this away
okay
the Democrats had a bill on the floor
last Congress to remove some statues I
walked down the floor and the Republican
I said oh I'm all for it
I think you should remove more statues
and I think you should change your name
there's not one Republican statue we
ever have to remove
the Jim Crow law
was brought to us by democrats okay
think about what happened in my office
you have a portrait of Abraham Lincoln
but you have a portrait of Joseph Rainey
you know Joseph rainius the first black
American Delight get elected to congress
he was a republican in 1870. you know in
the first black American Democrat was
elected 60 years later you know Joseph
Rainey wasn't the only black Republican
elected a number of them were elected so
then we had a presidential race that was
close
and so the Democrats partnered with the
Republicans and said you won but only on
one condition
you remove the federal troops from the
south and when they removed the federal
troops from the south lo and behold
Democrats then defeated Republicans and
what did they do when they defeated
Republicans
they changed the election raw and
brought Jim Crow laws in and picked
people based upon who can go there
remember the Republican party what it
was founded upon so when the Democrats
they removed five portraits of democrat
speakers okay you should but every
statue they wanted to remove was of a
Democrat sent to us from a state that a
Democrat majority was in that voted for
it that was accepted by a Congress that
was a majority of Democrats well why do
you keep your name then
change the name of the party we don't
have to change the name of the
Republican party because we were founded
on the idea that we're all equal we've
fought for the idea that people were
equal and fair and at times I've watched
when you say how can you change them
they don't know the history they don't
know the story and we need to tell it
more often so is that an education
fundamentally I mean is that why we have
to get the schools back more than
anything else because people believe now
that 1619 project was you know the true
story of recreate our history I mean the
idea that
Columbus is bad the the idea that um you
know you can't say Christmas I mean
our Founders were some of the most
religious people right we believe in
religious freedom though I mean the idea
in our schools what I'm most worried
about is
nobody in the Taliban or in the Chinese
Army are worried about a pronoun
nobody
okay with all respect
they just want to fight to win at the
end of the day we may have the right
pronouns but if we lose the war we're
out right and they only understand fear
but also the idea of our children I'm
not worried about my kids competing with
your kids I'm worried about our kids
competing with India and China
and the great equalizer in America is
the education system and why it's the
Democrats who fight charter schools and
this is the other thing that's so great
about States what Arizona has done what
Florida has done that allows your tax
dollars to follow your students so they
can go to a better school it's your
choice
you know that's going to change and who
does that help the most really those who
are lower income in America many times
many more minorities than others I'll
tell you today I was very excited I had
I had a school group that was from my
hometown here and it's a charter school
that was developed by this one family
the Grimms any of you ever eat these
baby carrots
okay they just sold but there was two
families in my district That Grew 80 of
all the carrots in the country and you
want a secret there's no such thing as a
baby care they're regular carrots we
chop them charge you more and you buy
them we love you food okay but good
night everybody
they're a great you know anybody these
families that own businesses and became
a very big business well they would put
all this money away to give scholarships
to their employees children go to
college I felt well you're not taking
them up well they weren't getting into
college they said well we've got to go
further down well they found the school
district weather so they were going to
pay to put in a charter school the
school district fought them but when
they finally got the charter school came
in and this is
90 will be immigrants in this community
they wear uniforms they take extra they
take extra classes right and the thing I
will tell you in the first two years
this school scores are competing with
the highest scores of anywhere in the
county and we just had for the first
time the eighth graders been there they
just came and had a picture with me in
the Rotunda and the excitement on these
kids faces that one little girl set up
you could tell that she she was the
class president she could write up on so
and so I want a picture of you and I'm
thinking you're going to be speaker one
day right I mean but how proud an
opportunity that's the great equalizer
in America when we talk about everybody
being equal but let's give them an equal
opportunity and let's not hold people
back
we got three minutes left and then you
got to get back to work so uh I will ask
you one tough one at the end you've
talked a lot about civility here uh the
audience obviously knows my feelings
about what's going on in Florida and
Governor DeSantis
obviously I supported Trump trump
supported you in in the speakership uh
this seems to be coming to a head one
way or another uh I've been concerned
about the civility also uh because I
don't want to see mutually assured
destruction if Trump ends up president
and DeSantis stays as my Governor
that'll be just fine with me if DeSantis
is President that'll be fine with me but
I don't want to destroy the whole thing
and I sense we really are in a dangerous
spot where we have a lot of the momentum
that you've talked about here and
Civility and the right ideas and things
of that nature
but it's like a Tinder Box in a way
maybe because of some of the
personalities I always think we should
do this whenever I sit down like I was
sitting down with some members yesterday
we were talking we're talking around
each other
what do we want to achieve
okay you take everybody out of running
what do you want to achieve you want to
stop the bad policies so you want
somebody else in the white house right
so you've got to understand too what's
the debate going to be about all the
things that Biden has done that somebody
else could do better
I think that resonates more with the
public it gets more people to vote it's
about addition not subtraction okay and
so it's tough when you get into
competition but members should really
see that whoever runs and lots of times
whoever the Front Runners today is not
the nominee and whatever we think the
issue is today is probably not going to
be the issue in another November from
now
um
but I think
the Democratic policies will always be
the issue right and I just don't think
the country wants another four years of
Joe Biden I just don't believe we can
sustain that and don't do damage to one
another that allows him to get in
because they're going to give you a lot
of bait don't take it
note he did not say Trump nor DeSantis
in that entire thing that was very slick
guys please make some noise from the
Speaker of the House Kevin McCarthy
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell